wir haben uns gestern erfreulicherweise
noch auf eine ganze menge maßnahmen
verständigen können um die
handlungsoptionen der länder zum
beherrschen dieser wirklich sehr sehr
schwierigen fragilen situation der
infektions dynamik gut in den griff
kriegen zu können und ich bin sehr
dankbar ich komme eben aus der anhörung
zu dem gesetzentwurf und diversen
änderungsanträgen die in vorbereitung
sind dass diese anhörung uns das auch
noch mal bestätigt hat dass wir hier
wirklich also sehr effiziente maßnahmen
einleiten bin dankbar dass es gestern
gelungen ist dass wir uns nochmal darauf
verständigt haben den maßnahmenkatalog
zu erweitern um kontakt beschränkungen
im persönlichen und im öffentlichen raum
anordnen zu können durch länder
verordnung das ist ganz wichtig neben
impfen und postern ist natürlich auch
die kontakt reduzierung mit einer er
wesentliches element es ist auch gut
dass es uns dass wir uns darauf
verständigt haben dass es eine
länderöffnungsklausel wieder gibt zwar
mit einschränkungen also ausgangssperren
werden wir nicht tolerieren nicht weiter
zulassen wir werden auch die schließung
von einzelhandelsgeschäften oder schulen
flächendeckend so in der form nicht also
ausschließen in der länder
öffnungsklausel aber ansonsten sind hier
wirklich alle maßnahmen die den ländern
im paragraf 28 absatz eins bis sechs
bislang zur verfügung stehen auch wird
eben auch in zukunft zur verfügung
stehen und es ist eine sehr gute
regelung und was mir besonders wichtig
es ist dass wir uns auch wirklich
draufhaben verständlichen können den
schutz der wunder rating gruppen also
den bewohnerinnen und bewohnern in
altenheimen senioren einrichtungen aber
auch in einrichtungen der
eingliederungshilfe
wirklich mit einer sehr stringenten
testpflicht sowohl für beschäftigte als
auch für besucher und auch für geimpfte
beschäftigte hier wirklich das
infektionsgeschehen versuchen nicht in
das haus in die einrichtung zu lassen
ich denke da sind wir auf einem sehr
sehr guten weg wir haben eine
dramatische situation in deutschland was
die korona pandemie angeht darauf müssen
wir mit entschlossenen maßnahmen
reagieren wir haben in den letzten tagen
über sehr viele weitergehende maßnahmen
gesprochen das ist notwendig angesichts
der weiteren verbreitung
des corona virus und der situation auf
unseren intensivstationen es geht darum
dass wir in besonderer weise diejenigen
schützen die in besonderer weise
betroffen sind also sprich menschen die
besonders verletzlich sind auch kinder
und jugendliche
es geht darum dass wir massnahmen
vorschlagen die im parlament besprochen
werden in den parlamenten sowohl im
bundestag wie auch in den landtagen es
geht darum dass wir massnahmen
beschliessen wollen die rechts sicher
und wirksam sind in dieser sich die
zugespitzten situation deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass wir offensichtlich in der
anhörung heute rückenwind bekommen haben
für solche weitergehenden maßnahmen
seien ist die kontakt beschränkungen sei
es zweig oder zweig + ich hoffe sehr
dass die ministerpräsidenten und
minister präsidentinnen sich darauf am
donnerstag bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz einigen
können die möglichkeit haben sie nach
unserem gesetz übrigens auch schon nach
dem ersten entwurf wir sehen den schutz
vor von arbeitsstätten deswegen 3g am
arbeitsplatz und homeoffice wir sehen
vor dass die schulen offen bleiben
können unter den gegebenen sicherheits
möglichkeiten und wir sehen vor dass die
länder weitere maßnahmen ergreifen
können dazu gehören keine pauschalen
ausgangssperren dazu gehört es aber dass
kontakt beschränkungen möglich sind dazu
gehört es auch dass veranstaltung mit
auflagen belegt werden können dazu
gehört es übrigens nicht dass man sport
treiben kann aber dass möglicherweise
große sportveranstaltungen nicht mehr so
stattfinden können gehört schon dazu wir
haben uns in besonderer weise
selbstverständlich den menschen gewidmet
die in alters und pflegeheimen leben
deswegen sehen wir vor dass es dort eine
testpflicht gibt für die beschäftigten
aber auch für besucherinnen und besucher
damit das virus möglichst keine chance
hat in diese einrichtungen
hineinzukommen wir haben auch immer
wieder darüber gesprochen was es für
weitere maßnahmen in den pflegeheimen
braucht und ob es weitere massnahmen
braucht darüber werden wir in weiteren
verfahren auch sprechen ich will aber
auch hier eindeutig sagen wenn ich da
missverstanden worden bin es gibt keine
einigung auf eine testpflicht in den
einrichtungen wir werden über solche
maßnahmen weiter zu sprechen haben mit
denen ampel partner wir haben jetzt
maßnahmen
das paket um maßnahmen erweitert
insbesondere in der wissenschaft bestand
konsens über alle lager hinweg dass auch
gewisse formen der kontakt beschränkung
möglich sein müssen um die
infektionszahlen und damit auch dass die
befürchtete überlastung des
gesundheitssystems abwenden zu können
das haben wir jetzt auch getan wir haben
auch abstrakte kapazitäts begrenzung mit
aufgenommen das bedeutet also unabhängig
von einem hygiene konzept können
ordnungsbehörden auch anordnen dass
beispielsweise in einer mehrzweckhalle
nur bestimmte
obergrenzen an personen zugelassen
werden ich bin sehr froh dass wir das
maßnahmenpaket auch um etwas erweitert
haben warum auch wir als fdp uns lange
bemüht haben nämlich den schutz der
wohlhabenden gruppen insbesondere in den
altenheimen zu verbessern wir folgen da
jetzt dem weg des landes
schleswig-holstein ist in dem wir auch
gesetzlich jetzt eine tägliche
testpflicht unabhängig vom impfstatus
für die dort beschäftigten anordnen das
ist ein enormer fortschritt denn wir
wissen ja dass dort sehr viele menschen
leben die sehr empfindlich auf eine
infektion reagieren dort sind in der
vergangenheit die meisten menschen
gestorben und dort sorgen wir jetzt
entschlossen für schutz darüber hinaus
sorgen wir auch mit weiteren maßnahmen
wie etwa 3g am arbeitsplatz dafür dass
wir
hören schutz vor infektionen dann auch
vor schweren verläufen in der breite und
damit eben auch dass die befürchtete
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
abzuwenden und das ist insgesamt ein
sehr gutes paket mit dem man corona sehr
entschlossen bekämpfen kann